Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to...
Five Nights at Freddy's Help Wanted!
Hiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii
Am I supposed to wave at you?
I'm waaaaaaaaaaaaving
Oh, that looked like a middle finger, but don't mind that.
Hey, you're just like me!
You've got weird green hands, that's probably connected.
Also this...
doesn't say "out of order" anymore.
[crunchy]
hOoHHH, what did I do?
Oh!!
Shit!
(Gets creepy as music starts playing, like a run down vinyl player)
Whoa! (music continues)
Oh I hate it. Okay actually I hate that. That's awful. (Music slows)
What did I just do?
What?
ohHHHHH
Oh (music stops)
Wait, whoa, whoa whoa whoa, whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa... What the fuck?
Oh
Oh !
O- Oh! Oh, oh, oh
Okay, I don't like being a void of death
Uh, this looks like a void of death!
I don't know what this is but...
You!
Uh (the subtitles in game are spoke by a young girl?)
Yes :/
Uh,
Okay?
Uh huh...
Oh!
Uh...
Oh okay, I hate this place.
Um, okay...
what?
Huh?
Oh,
ᵒ ᵏ ᵃ ʸ
I don't like how quiet-
OOH
Uh huh...
What the fuck
Wha-?
Oh
Okay, you have to go, perfect.
Yes!
Uh oh...
Wha- wai- [unintelligible]
Tha- That's nonsensical nothingness!
That means nothing!
What are you talking about? What does that even mean?
Oh shit, we're still here.
Oh God. Oh
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait,
Night five? Wait,
Night five?! OH!
OH!
OHH WAIT WHOA WHOA WHOA WHOA
Whoa, so there's a there's a...
There's a freaking hard mode?!
Oh God, hang on, I wanna see-
Show time, baby!
What does this button on the si- OW! That was my mic.
Sorry,
-Button on side. I don't know what that do.
There's my mic. I don't know where I am
Arright, Let's go out of fucky mode.
Weee!
Hey- oh
You're not there anymore...
Actually wait let's go back in,
I wanna see something.
You're not there. Okay, you're not there, but I'm gonna go to the prize counter while I'm in weird mode.
Anything weird?
Okay
cAndy! Oh-
Hoh-oh!
You're hidden!
Okay..
I found you though!
Okay, that's another tape I- I guess...
Who?...
Nooo...
Oh...
Oh yeah, "budget thing"...
Yeah, okay...
Heh heh heh heh, yeah...
oH that's "normal"
Uh-huh...
Right, okay...
Yeah, that makes total sense, TOTAL sense...
Yeah, "usable code" that you just GRABBED from a circuit board and put in your game, all to see-
WEEEEeeeeeeyyyyyy-
Whoa, hi...
How you doing there?
Oh, you're fine! No, I like you. I like you. I like you.
Okay. All right. I'm gonna get out here. uH-uH
Cachunkis! Oh, bye-bye.
Oh, you're still there. Okay... Are you closer?
Wait a minute. Are you closer?
Are you waving more vigorously? Hi. I can out-wave, BITCH! okay...
So, um, that's that's a no-no
Uh...
So we got these other- uh, other things to do, but I- I've also never finished... Five Nights at Freddy's 1-
-for this, so...
I'm gonna go ahead and uhm-
Imma DO that
You don't mind, because I don't mind, but if you don't mind, I'm gonna go ahead and finish up Five Nights at Freddy's 1
Because I'm- I don't wanna- that to be
You know not here....
So whoo.
Oh shit.
Oh God.
aH! Eh- none of that. Okay.
aH! Eh- none of that. Okay. (these subtitles are classic phone guy)
Holy shit
I just got the-
EGH!
Okay, we're fine- I remember how to play the game, I do!
Wait but what- didn't they say something about their some-being something up this hall?
I have no idea... hang on...
Is this a door?
oh! oH! OH! FOXY NO! AH! FUCK!
God! I was- the- eh other one!
Fuck you man!
OH Celebrate. Yeah, okay celebrate- yeah, celebrate my ass.
Okay. All right. We already got Bonnie on the move here.
So that's okay...
It's fine until they get to the door!
Did I press that? Okay, whatever. I didn't mean to press that. Okay, you move. Oh-
ooOOOH!
We got to on the move. Hey, wait-
OH, that's awful. I hate that.
All right, that's awful. Um
Everything else is fine
eeuugghhh I don't like that. Okay- Oh God. Okay. All right. We're fine.
Holy shit.
Fuck. Okay.
Turn- Okay. You're- I'm- I'm fine
I panic for nothing
Okay, dUUUAAAAHH. I hate that. Okay hit that... I see neither of- okay.
Bonnie's coming down that way
I hear something here..
I swear to god I hear something...
uH!
Okay, I hear something. I don't know what I'm hearing, but I'm hearing something-no good.
Oh my god. Okay, Bonnie's still there.
Where's Chica?
where’s chica?
WUUUAAAHHHHHHH
WHHYYY
WHY
OH MY GOD
WHAT
WHY
WHO
AND WHY
wh- what was there?
there was NOTHING there
what was there?
NOTHING.
YOU LIAR
Don't lie to me.
Don't lie to me
what was-
HEEEYY. WHOOA, okie, you're in the closet
that's fine
oOHH Foxy okay..
I don't know
WHAAA
WHA NO
NAAAHH, NAAAWW
WAAIII-
WAAAAAIIIT A MINUTE
AHH OH
FUCKING WHAT?!?!
(so sad..)
HEH HEH
HEH HEH HEHH
*echoing...
uh huh.
Okay, I'm getting better at-, at hitting the door lights
so that's good
Foxy is not there.
okay
we're fine
WHOOO we're fine, okay
I DON'T LIKE THAT WHAT IS THAT?!
CUT THAT MUSIC
Cut that music, YOU SHIT, okay, you're there.
That's fine.
You're not there yet. I don't think
Okay, no, no. no.
WHOA WHAT THE FUCK?
wait
but I-
wait-
oh god why?
OH SHIT.
Okay you're there, but that's fine
Y- you're not there.
You're behind my door
For some reason
I dunno why
Oh shit.
Oh shit
But that's fine
You're- you're on the move
I think
You're still fine
OOH SHIT
Ooh God, okay, you're fine.
You movin'?
You move-  I HEAR, wha-
AHHHHH
OHHHH GOD
WHY
FFFFFFFAACKING
HEY!
oh god
You movin now?
Oh you're fine, you're fine
It's fine. Technically speaking.
I hate that
OH I hate that
oh my god I hate that
okay I hate that
Um, well we're fine. What?
ooh fuck okay you're fine
You still there?
okay
you're gone
ok fuck
fuck
OH SHIT
My dick
okay
oh fuck, okay, well
here we go!
DUN DUN DUN DUN
okay cool
you're still there
*ol' foxy makin that weird bangin noise
Okay
I tried to- BUHH
I tried to-
Okay you're not there anymore (BOO!)
FUCK, FAAACK
FUCK
EUUGH FAACK YOUU
I don't know man
Okay, where's foxy? Oh who knows?
Freddy's still on the stage
UH
You still there?
AAHH
WHY ARE YOU STILL THERE?!
fUCK!
Why are you still there?
I can't see when you go back
I guess I gotta wait for you to pop up on stage again for some reason- turn off. Okay.
Oh my god, okay.
Are you back on stage? No. You're. Still. There.
ProBaBLy
I don't know
YA HAVEN'T GONE ANYWHERE
GO AWAY
Oh my god, are you still there? Are you gone?
Have you gone home?
HOH MY GOD FINALLY okay
kkkyaawwfffeeeeeuuughgh
Huh? Stop, look here. No stop.
OKay, where are they? I don't know
There's Bonnie okie, Bonnie there
Okay, lil TOOCHES lil TOOCHES
LIL ToooChES
Just -- That's all it TakES - LiL TooOCheS, lil tOOocHEs
that's all it is 4AM, I've got this
In the bag
So long that I keep tOOcHiN
just little by little
Hooh shit. Okay. Wait, what the fuck? Oh hi.
Okay you're fine, you're fine, you're fine, IT'S FINE
This is really weird
That's horrible, but technically it's fine
Because...
BeAcOOAAZZ
you'll be there
And-
DU DU DUM DUM
OOH SHIT
WAAW FUCK
WHY, WAAW FUCK
NO NO NO WAIT NO that's a-
EEYYY NO
OH BAH , I FFF, CHICA
who- who the fuck?
OH GOD OH GOD
oh god um, um
this is bad but I got 30% power
So technically I could stay here for a long time
Technically. Technically speaking. I am fine
Technically speaking. I could stay here till- 6 a.m. Because I am fine. I got plenty of power left you all are assholes
Why don't you go away? Oh, you're gone. Are you? Okay?
That's a little power left for me
to save cause I'm a conservatory
kind of guy
Conservationally is that- who's that?
That Freddy? That Freddy on the move?
This is only night 2. Can I mention that this is only night 2? That everyone is being this-
-dickey with me? okay. you're fine stop
oh my god
HEH HEH
Oh fuck. Okay that fuck. What was that? What was that? Oh, don't laugh at me
You're fine. What? Fuck,  UH
Okay, you're bo- you're there and you're there. That's that's good. That's that's actually okay
HUAAAAAAAAA
HOOOOOOH MY GOD 2%
HOOOOOLY SHIT 2%
UAAAGHHH
UAAAAAAAGGHHH
Oh there I go there goes my power well, it's okay cuz I win oh
Oh
*le sigh*
Oh. You? You're the worst oh
LudULEDuluu
Look at slappy arms. Listen buddy, lis-. AAAHH
WHY DID- WEH- WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT? DID I EAT THAT? (audible heavy breathing)
WHAT THE F*CK DID I EAT THAT?
WHAT THE F*CK DID I EAT THAT? (mark there's children watching )
DID I- WAIT- wait a minute did I just eat that?
yes...
you did.
What-
yOu waNnA Run tHa-
You wanna run that by me aga --
I ATE?
What?
Ohhkay
Alright. Sure. Yeah. Okay. Fine. Yeah.
Uh, alright yea okay, alright, that's, that's fine
Didn't know that would happen. But okay shut up. I don't have time. I know I don't have time
HEEHH HEHEHEEH
It's good
It's good. It's a good thing (no it's not)
It's a good- stop go away. It's good thing ooh shit.
Okay here comes, okay here comes, Chica but that's okay
Chica could just go marching on. The- Chica could go marching on. Oh, whoa.
Whoa. WHoa. WHOa. WHOA. WHOA. WHOA. WHOA. WHOA NONE OF THAT
Whoa, what the fuck?
You kidding me. What is happening? What's happening? What's happening? Who's having a circus? You're not there? Okay, you're fine
Don't, don't do that
Okay, don't do that. Whatever you just did don't do it
Whatever you're doing right now, don't okay
Okay
Oh Boy, oh boy. I don't Chica nowhere, I don't see chica nowhere, I don't see anybody nowhere OH fuck
Okay, you're it's fine. It's fine fine. Oh shit. Okay, it's it's not fine. Okay, it's not fine
It's it's big . Okay you're there. That's fine. You stay there WAAAAH OH GOD
(Foxy scratching and banging on the door) Oh fuck. Okay. You're still there. That's fine. Okay
Okay. All right. That's fine. Huh? And then we're good. You're still there? No, God. Okay. Stop that go here up there
I don't know where Freddy is but hesAAA COOMMIINN. Okay, but I'm ready. I'm ready for Freddy
I'm losing a lot of power though. So this is not ideal. I got to be better at jabbing my fINgieS. Okay, you're there
You're there oh boy. I'm back in back in old fashion. Okay, I think I saw Freddy on the move there
He was going somewhere
Okay, he's going somewhere. I don't know where I don't know where and I don't care cuz I got this
Who's moving what's on the move huh? Okay you again are you gonna stop and look like a weirdo? No
No, you're going right back. Yeah. Yeah, you should as you should as you should as you should go by. Yeah
Yeah. Yeah as you should. Oh fuck
You're fine. It's fine. Okay, that's fine
God this the original
I swear to god the original
So. Fucking. Scary
Every part of it. Like there you are
I see you Freddy tucked in the corner there like the creep you is. Okay stop.
Oh, they're looking here. I'm checking for Bonnie.
You're still there, that's fine. I don't need to look at you
Okay, you're good. You're good. Okay, you're not there. You're not there
Definitely not there. Okay, good. Oh, fuck. Oh fuck. Oh fuck. What was that? What was that? Wait,
No, it's fine. Is it fine? I don't think it's fine.
Does it sound fine? I don't remember what that's all about
I think it's fine. I think it's fine. It's fine. Oh my god. Okay, it's fine. It's just noise
It's just a bunch of noise
Okay
*message from mark's phone
Oh fuck was that my-?
Okay, there's-
BAAAAHHH
Okay. Get, okay you move on right by
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Okay
Fuck
But you?
Shouldn't be there? Okay. He's not there
You're still there. You're not there. Oh my god. Oh my-
AAAHHH
OH FUCK
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. I don't have enough power for this. What is that? What's- what is that? Oh my god. Okay.
Oh you're gone
See, are you there? Okay, you're not there, but you might be there god damn it. Okay
Okay, fuck
What am I looking for? I don't know
(sigh) fuck
Okay, who did that? AAAHH
Okay, you're right there I gotta keep that closed, cause I remember,
I remember that's bad news, no matter what. That's bad news. Okay
Okay, maybe it's not maybe, maybe I'm wasting power. I probably am. Can I get that off there? Okay
Okay, I think it's fine. I think I'm panicking with that door. Oh shit. No. Oh, well, that's bad anyway
Okay, that's fine
Okay, it's fine. That's bad news, but I'm gonna die anyway
Because I'm about to run out of power and there's nothing I can do about it
So, you know c'est la vie it was good run here I go
ohhh fuck
oh please-
OOOHHHHHHHHH
YAAS!
YAS, YAS, YAS, YAS, YAS
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god
Fuck. let's try not to eat my prize this time. Oh
OH
That's worse that's
But I mean, it kind of looks tasty.
i LikE YoUR baCk bOObs
uhm
Eugh, okay. All right, so I ate that
Not sure why
It was tasty though. It was pretty good, pretty good. I liked it
But I don't know why I ate it
Didn't know I could eat it.
That I am
yea..
Okay. Yeah, could you make it any more obvious for me? What I'm supposed to do?
Mr. Heavy-handed over there. All right one more night
Okay, well that's no good. But hey that's not gonna happen to me, not this time cause I'm an expert at
TooOCHin BuTtoNS, ToouCHin tOOuchIES
which is what I'm doin
just tOoOChiN alL oVeR thE bUTtONs
They're going up here strumming up and down the tOOuChieS. We'rE GoINg DOwn tO ToOch Town BabY
And I'm gonna TOOCH all over these buttons so gingerly, so gently no one's gonna get me,
no one's gonna get me
Oh, he's gonna get me. Oh my god. Everyone's gonna get me. Oh god. Okay. All right
Everyone's gonna go WHHY
I'M LOOKIN RIGHT AT YOU
Why would you be like that? Is that just like something is gonna happen?
Oh god. Why? Okay. No reason why that's fine. All good. Everyone. Everyone's off the stage
AH AAHHHHH OHH FUCK, FUCK
(Foxy scratching and banging on the door again) Holy shit. Okay that
(Foxy still trying to get in, being all scary oooooh)
That's too close. You're done? (nope)
DAAA FUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUCK??
You weren't done were you? You weren't done? I guess you weren't done. All right. Well..
I guess he wasn't done. I guess- I guess he wasn't done is the lesson I learned there. All right. Okay
Okay, I don't- still, your steps. I don't know. You stay right there..
You don't mess with me coz I won't mess with you
You don't want these messing fingers, messing with you chica, cuz I'm about to mess you up. Yes
Yeah, you heard the threat, you ran like a little baaaabyyyy
Like a little baby in the face of pure DEATH. THESE FINGERS SPELL DEATH
I'm gonna shove them, soooo far inside your suit. I'm gonna wind up your spring locks. This is all it is
This is what I remember even in the main game. This is all of us
You ignore all the bullshit noise that are happening around you because there's a lot of bullshit noise happening. Don't get me wrong
There's a lot of that happening, but for me all I care about, okay here comes Freddy. He's coming down
He- I see the eyes. I see the eyes. They're OK the eyes are there. So Freddy's there
Okay, stop
Freddy's there, still looking down. Bonnie hasn't shown up yet, which is fine. How's Foxy doing? Close. But that's okay.
What are we doing?
Nothing
Doin' nothing
Stop god damn it.
Okay, we're doing nothing
Oh my god.
Oh my god
AAAAAAAHHHH
OOOWWW FUCKING GOD
GOD
I WAS LOOKING RIGHT AT THE SCREEN YOU WEREN'T GONE YET
What the fuck that's unfair
I wasn't even gone! You weren't even gone.
um
Okay. OH SHIT. Oh fuck. (Foxy's back)
That's how I got killed
He switched right as I went to that one and that's no good. That is a no bueno. Okay your oh shit
Okay, you're, you're fine.
Oh shit okay you- as soon as this moves, unless you okay you're fine
And then you oh god, I'm just gonna close that because I don't fuckin trust that at all. They're both stacked up there
That's how is any of that fair? You there? No, you're not there. Why are you not there?
Oh, you're already about to reset again. Okay. Oh shit. Wait what?
What the fuck?
Okay, apparently not. Okay
What are you doing?
(DUM DUM DUM DU DUM DUM)
Do something!!
Fuck this door. I'm gonna open it up again cuz I can't waste that power unless you-  OH FUCK. Okay stopping that
Stopping that you go ahead and try, try me bitch. Try me
Yeah, try me
Try me. I'm almost out of power. Okay, you're there. That's fine. Okay, that's totally fine
You there, you stay there for as long as you need
It's all fine. I got 17% power. I got everything I need right here
right there
HEH HEH HEH
What is that?
HEH HEH
Oh shit, okay. He's coming down
Okay. What are you gonna stop there? Oh, yeah, you're okay. Fuck that shit. Fuck that noise
OK you..
Are now probably right behind there. I'm not gonna mess with that shit
Unless you are right behind there. Are you right behind there? Oh fuck he's right behind there. Isn't he?
OH WHAT THE FUCK NOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
HEH HEH
HEH HEH HEH
*echoing...
You dick
Okay- who's- who's  walking? Okay, we got, we got chica walking up which is fine
That's a stop walk. I don't like that. I don't like that at all. Okay, so
Chicas moving back
There unless chicas. Oh shit. Okay, you're coming up, which is fine
You're going by
Okay, and he's gone so that door is just staying closed from now until eternity
that door is
Now the closed door. Forever. I don't need the light, I don't need to know about it, that door just stays closed
I don't care what anybody says that door staying closed and then you? Did you move? No, not yet
Okay, I'm just playing with one door closed. That's it. Okay and boink. Oh you what?
Oh shit, I don't like that. I don't like that. What, are you there?
Okay, apparently not. What the fuck? okay, I don't like that- I don't trust, that, at all.
Hey!!!
(Sigh) Fuck okay. Yes! with these hands. I did it. Aw, FUCK. Okay. Cool. Good good. Great
Great, great. Great great. Great. Great. Great. Great. Give me my prize...
Give me my prize...
Ho! Bonnie!
Wow, you look so good you couldn't ever eat me
You couldn't even dream of eating me
You couldn't handle the taste that I have in my gob and look at that
I was right. You can't eat me. Whoa. Well, oh yeah, Bonnie? Well, you can eat my fist no
ooo-BOINK! Ah-bedlldldldldlddldldldldldldldldldldldl
dldldldldldldldl (grows higher pitched)
Doink
uwaaaaaaeh....
(fart noise)
Dead. That is
The original five nights at Freddy's
fucking
terrifying but
Hey, I did it so
You can take that one home
to the books
So thank you everybody so much for watching
this episode
of Five Nights
At Fraddies VR: Help Wanted. It's been fun, it been real fun
So thank you everybody so much for watching and there's gonna be more five nights at Freddy's coming real soon
I'll let you guys know when I'm able to post more but you can just check my channel subscribe
Ring that bell
Fulingaling that like button whatever you want to do to make sure that you get notified of new Five Night's at Freddy's.
So thank you everybody so much for watching check the description for even more
Videos on this wonderful topic and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh-Bye!!
*outro music*